a coveted question is there an end in
sight i mean what is the metric that
would be used for maybe getting rid of
the mass if we continue
to make the progress on vaccinations yes
there's an end in sight because i think
it will put a lid on a winter surge that
said that winter surge last year
particularly in southern california was
profound and pronounced
this week governor newsome announced
that california kids will all be
required to be vaccinated
once it gets fda approval let's talk
about that and more with gloria allred
on the left and dave rubin on the right
debating each other for the first time
uh all right dave let's start with you i
know this is an issue you're especially
passionate about what do you make of
california's vaccine
mandates oh it's completely ridiculous
like the federal vaccine mandates are to
be very clear i think that if anyone
wants to get the vaccine and they want
to wear a mask and they want to stay at
home or whatever it is that they want to
do you absolutely have that right and
you should consult with your doctor and
you should take into account your age
and your health and medical history all
of those things the idea that a year and
a half a year and a half after two weeks
to flatten the curve a phrase that we
don't talk about anymore did we ever
flatten the curve why don't we talk
about that curve anymore the idea that
now it's about some sort of magical as
joe biden said which is what gavin
newsom's alluding to it's about some
sort of 97 or 98 percent government
mandated vaccine and then for kids
you know kids have a point
zero zero two percent chance of dying
from covin that is cdc numbers as of
march uh everyone else is getting
vaccinated in essence so the teachers
are vaccinated the administrators are
vaccinated we know kids aren't sharing
it with each other this is just constant
government overreach and where are the
good liberals you know california is
supposed to be a liberal state liberals
used to fight for individual rights and
civil liberties but they've just folded
in the name of uh progressive
authoritarianism
gloria are you a good liberal
you know i'm a progressive proud
progressive i might add but i also
believe in science and this is really
not about rights it's about life and
death and of course kids can also be
carriers of covid
and in addition to that i think it's
really important to understand
this is not a political issue it
shouldn't be it should be a scientific
and a health issue and i ask you dave
do you think there should not be a
mandate for kids in schools to have to
get vaccine for chickenpox for mumps for
polio for so many other vaccines that
they are required to have in order to go
to school all of those things were
tested for years as we know we rushed
out this vaccination but this is not i'm
not saying people should not get
vaccinated i'm saying it should be left
up to choice but you just said something
very very dangerous right there for a
lawyer this is not about rights
since when is it not about rights in the
united states we have god-given rights
that are protected under the
constitution and the bill of rights and
if we're suddenly saying oh this isn't
about rights because there is some virus
out there with basically a 99 recovery
rate and i just gave you the cdc numbers
for children yes children could transmit
the disease although they rarely do but
the parents are all vaccinated if
they're good decent citizens
so i i don't really understand the
connection actually are you a good
decent citizen are you vaccinated
it's nobody's business whether i'm
vaccinated that's like me asking you the
last time you got laid i mean it's just
irrelevant all right so you know what's
really relevant is that it's one thing
if you have the right
to choose from your questions
nor yours is mine let clearly finish
if you have the right to choose what you
should do with your own body i respect
that but when what you choose to do
can
be dangerous to others
then we're in a whole different area and
so for example people
are mandated to wear seat belts when
they drive why because if they get into
an accident it's not only going to be
dangerous to them it's going to be
dangerous to others people can smoke
knowing the danger and the risks of
smoking but they can't just put
secondary smoke into somebody else's
apartment or home or you know smoke you
know in places where it can be very
dangerous to other individuals that's
what this is about and by the way even
for your own choice
if you exercise your choice not to get a
vaccine you get to do that but you also
have to pay the consequences of that and
the consequences may be that you're not
going to be able to have a job anymore
the consequences may be that you're
going to end up in the hospital with
serious covet and you may die and
because you're overloading the icus in
the hospital people who need care for
cancer or heart disease or other
illnesses may not be able to get a bed
because you were irresponsible in not
getting the vaccine gloria frankly it's
very obvious to me that you're a
progressive because what lies under
every progressive is a really uh sort of
hysterical authoritarian everyone else
have to make a decision
a decision for themselves here we're in
los angeles right now i was just over at
the studio that i couldn't get into over
there which which hospitals in los
angeles are overrun right now
look let me just tell you something
first of all you made a sexist remark
calling a woman hysterical is very very
sexist so i think he should stay on the
issues instead of engaging in name
calling look we've had surges we've had
you were telling me i was in california
we don't need to wait for the
for the point at which there is a crisis
as is going on in many many states where
there are no icu beds available and
people have to drive miles and miles to
another state to even get an icu bed
some people have died before they got
there
yeah i mean i guess the researchers for
this show can show me the videos of of
all the overrun hospitals that nobody
has seen there's been no pictures of
them and no videos of them but but again
i'm not for people getting sick i'm for
choice i believe people can make the
right medical choices for themselves i
mean really if we go down this route if
we go down this route where you have to
do things for your health and to make
sure that hospitals don't get overrun
there's going to be an awful lot of bad
things we're going to have to do to
overweight people because as you know
being overweight and being diabetic
is one of the biggest factors in covid
morbidity
are we suddenly going to say that
overweight people should be what are we
going to force them to diet are we going
to not give them health insurance 99 of
the people who are in the critical care
in the icu beds are unvaccinated people
that alone should tell you why people
need to get vaccinated and also children
even if there is a small risk for the
younger children right now
they can be carriers and bring it home
to their parents and their grandparents
and many many others
i'd like somebody to fact check the 99
percent of hospitals are on backfield
but gloria but gloria if you believe the
vaccine works so these kids that i would
not force it's up to the parent to
decide uh how would they be getting the
parent sick if the vaccine works and the
parents are vaccinated
well there's let because there is still
a risk that they can get covet if
they're vaccinated they are less likely
to end up in the icu and die
most people who are unvaccinated have a
much higher risk of ending up in the icu
and dying let me put a
try to put a button on this and start
where this conversation started which
was the question that i asked governor
newsom which is how does this end uh
what is the benchmark for some of this
to stop
dave your thought on that
yeah it doesn't end in a place like
california where we've elected people
that really enjoy this power which is
why gavin newsom is always smiling as
he's telling you about all the lockdowns
and when he was at the school this
morning telling you about you know
mandating vaccines for kids but not for
teachers and not for prison guards which
is what he did yesterday it doesn't end
in a place like this because there this
isn't really about a virus i would say
it's about a mind virus related to
controlling people but it probably
doesn't end here you know again two
weeks to flatten the curve was a year
and a half ago now it's 98 and then
maybe we'll let you get back to normal
this is human nature it will always move
now we're being told
kids might spread it to adults who are
vaccinated do you see how this thing
keeps moving dave you know all i can
tell you is this
that there are many conservative radio
talk show hosts and feel free to fact
check that who were anti-vaxxed and and
gave the same script lines that you've
been giving about okay it's your
individual choice and all that and as
they were dying in the icu they begged
for the vaccine it was too late for them
and they urged everyone please that get
the vaccine because they admitted they
were wrong not to get it
again i never said that i'm anti-backs
everyone should make whatever choice is
right for themselves but i would say
listen to some of the nba players over
the last couple days who are taking a
brave stand by saying you know we're
young healthy people maybe we've got uh
coveted before and we have natural
antibodies why aren't we allowed to talk
about any of that stuff and instead we
have to
government that's why you saw them on
television and heard them they are
talking about it but i but they're not
scientists and good luck to them uh but
uh you know that's a ridiculous it's a
very good safe choice as far as i'm
concerned
uh all right i guess we're gonna have to
leave it there because we're out of time
i guess they're not coming together on
this issue but
it is but i'd love to dance with you
together with you one day dave yeah
alex's show i will gladly dance with you
regardless of vaccination status well no
i won't dance with you if you're
unvaccinated i don't want to be anywhere
near you thank you very much
i did not say whether i was or was well
you'll have
[Laughter]
let's leave it there i guess that's a
sign of where we are as a country right
now but at the end we can agree on on
some things as well dave thank you for
coming on the show for the very first
time really enjoyed it it was my
pleasure if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell